Russia has been on The Retreat on the
battlefield but on the offensive through
diplomatic channels and in public with
more unsubstantiated accusations that
Ukraine plans to detonate an explosive
with radioactive material or a dirty
bomb and blame Russia
in Moscow the head of Russia's nuclear
biological and chemical defense expanded
on the defense Minister's claims of the
previous day
according to the information we possess
two Ukrainian institutions are
commissioned to build a so-called dirty
bomb The Works are in the final stages
now a detonation of such a device could
be disguised as a spontaneous explosion
of a Russian low-yield nuclear weapon
it's a claim that's been roundly
dismissed here in Kiev and in Western
capitals as transparently false
Ukraine's foreign minister has invited
in inspectors from the international
atomic energy agency to refute it the
question being asked here is whether
this is Russia trying to throw sand in
the eyes of its enemies or whether it
really doesn't intend to use some kind
of nuclear device what do you think
Russia expects to gain from making just
this threat even if it doesn't go
through with it
I think Russia tries to demonstrate that
the
Eid can continue this war
permanently and to go to another levels
of escalation and maybe it's impossible
it's important for Russia to demonstrate
this possibility
well Russia presses its nuclear
narrative it continues to launch
Conventional Weapons targeted
increasingly at Ukraine's energy
facilities among those weapons
iranian-made drones
foreign
president warning Israel on Monday that
Iran might receive Russian nuclear
technology in return and renewing his
calls for Israel to provide its Iron
Dome missile defense
if we had immediately secured our skies
when faced with a missile drone threat
Russia would not even have a motive now
to go into Iran and offer it something
in return for assistance with Terror
in Berlin more calls for help this time
for longer term economic aid ahead of
Tuesday's International Conference on
rebuilding Ukraine reconstruction though
requires an end to the war Russia is
instead warning of an uncontrolled
escalation
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Kiev